if you're a student chances out you're
pretty smart and if you're pretty smart
you probably understand the importance
of looking after our environments it can
keep looking after us and being a
student you'll probably also on the
lookout for ways to save some money
fortunately it's possible to do both of
these things at once
so here are the top seven ways that you
can save the planet and yourself some
cash number one stop eating meat won't
turn off the video it seems that many
people would rather die than give up
eating meat and to be honest I don't
completely understand that I used to
feel that way but the fact of the matter
is that the single most effective way
that you can reduce your impact on the
environment is to salt eating meat which
is why I did it looking at global
greenhouse gas emissions by sector we
see that the largest contributions come
from energy generation industry
transport and agriculture links to all
the studies that I refer to by the way
will be in the description below data
indicates that the average Westerner
emits 10 tons of co2 per year two and a
half tonnes of which comes from that
food now that's much more carbon emitted
per person than the global average but
this analysis has been done for
Americans so we're limited to that
vegetarians have roughly two-thirds the
agricultural carbon impact of meat
eaters at one point seven tons emitted
per person per year the majority that
difference comes from just not eating
beef or lamb vegans have a still lower
carbon impact at one point five tonnes
emitted per person per year thanks to
not eating dairy products and they also
have superpowers if the world is going
to avoid catastrophic climate change we
have to move away from a culture where
meat consumption is everywhere
a 2014 report found that the world's
meat industry causes more carbon
emissions than the world's Planes Trains
cars and ships combined and that's not
to say that nobody should eat meat just
not eating meat during the week would
significantly cut your personal carbon
emissions as with swearing off beef or
lamb and furthermore meat is expensive
estimates indicate that you could say
about 750 dollars or 500 pounds a year
by going veggie there's a good reason
why meat was originally only for special
occasions if you want to save yourself
some serious money and do the planet
some serious good then swear off meat
during the week all entirely number 2
minimize your food waste the other way
to reduce the carbon impact of your food
is to reduce the amount of food that you
buy and then don't consume here in the
UK we check out a nest
seven million tons of food per year
that's over 100 kilos per year per
person of which at least half is still
edible and about 50% of food waste
doesn't come from retailers but takes
place here in homes here at the
University of Exeter a recent study
showed that students specifically
checkout nearly 800 grams of food per
week and that's not even including the
GBS cheesy chips that you buy and then
forget about all this waste adds up to
an estimated 470 pounds per person per
year so you can save serious money that
could be better spent on booze or you
know textbooks by learning to limit your
food waste
most of the food we've been in homes is
either food that we've prepared and then
not eaten so we've got our portion sizes
wrong or food that's poured for we can
even cook with it so poor planning and
impulse buys to fix this one plan your
meals for the week in advance right a
shopping list and stick to it to store
fruit and veg appropriately and
refrigerate stuff ropes appropriate 3
learn how to use your leftovers and new
recipes in particular i recommend the
BBC good food website and for consider
sharing your food with housemates or
with other students in schemes like food
share edinburgh if we waste less food
then we don't need to buy as much then
we tell us they need to order as much
then the farmers don't need to produce
as much and so we have lower global
agricultural greenhouse gas emissions
simples
number three be energy efficient along
the same lines are trying to reduce our
food waste by reducing our energy waste
we're reducing our personal contribution
to the single largest sector of
greenhouse gas emissions into the
atmosphere and also save serious money
we're talking hundreds of pounds a year
if you do this right so to help you do
just that one only ball as much water as
you need and don't overfill your kettle
water takes a serious amount of energy
to boil and so cost you serious money to
ask yourself if your house thermostat or
central heating if you're lucky enough
to have one has to be set as high as it
is even reducing it by one degree could
save you 75 pounds per year per house 3
wash your clothes on a 30 degree cycle
compared to a 60 degree cycle you use
30% less energy and potentially save
yourself another 75 pounds per year for
if you're not using something turn it
off and no standby doesn't count
this might sound obvious but if you're
not using the lights in a room then
you're saving money and if you do this
consistently across all your devices
like TVs and laptops then you could save
up to 120
pounds per year five and lastly if you
have a freezer then defrosting it on the
regular so once a year can save you
serious money as the freezer doesn't
need to work quite so hard to reach the
same low temperatures a freezer badly in
need of the defrost can say it cost you
up to 70 pence extra per day so by
defrosting a freezer you're probably
gonna sale about 80 pounds per year on
your energy bill these are just some
tips there are some fantastic articles
available online such as those below
that I hope you save even more money
that you could put towards that round
that you've definitely been dodging for
the past few weeks number four use
public transport kind of an obvious one
by this point but as transport from such
a large part of global greenhouse gas
emissions and it's 20% of our emissions
here in UK by taking public transport
I'm not driving cars wherever possible
you can make a serious decrease in your
personal carbon budget one study
estimated that accounting for production
it can't a ver äj-- 271 grams of carbon
dioxide being emitted per person per
mile while a bus averaged 101 grams per
person per mile or better yet cycle even
accounting for the increase in calories
that you'll have to take in from cycling
everyday a bike averages just 21 grams
of carbon dioxide emitted per mile so
significantly lower than cars or buses
in fact if everyone in Europe cycled as
much as almost Velo file citizens the
danes then it's estimated the Euro could
cut its transport emissions by a quarter
as well as being great for the
environment cycling is also free once
you've bought yourself a cheap bike and
campuses of great places do that just
make sure that you also buy D lock to
keep your bike safe great exercise and
it gives you buns of steel number five
make smart consumer choices in a
capitalist society often the loudest
actions we make are those with our money
choosing to buy products or knots to buy
products based on their impact on the
environment
Kinji significant change in particular
be careful about which products you buy
that contain palm oil palm oil is one of
the key drivers of deforestation in
places such as Indonesia
Madagascar and Malaysia where the
rainforest is cut down to make way for
vast plantations of the African oil palm
tree the oil from this tree is
incredibly useful substance that has a
wide range of properties that make it
useful in about half of all household
products in the Western world its
properties are so wide-ranging that it
appears in everything from lipstick to
biofuels to ice cream the problem is the
world
increasing appetite for parma led to
huge habitat destruction and is the
major reason why species such as the
orangutan at least in march and tiger
along with hundreds of others are facing
extinction and the industry is also
linked with the exploitation of local
communities and child labor at this
point i'd only try and put something
funny in the video to lighten the mood
but it's kind of difficult when you're
dealing with something as horrible as
this so to make a difference if you're
going to be buying products that do
contain palm oil make sure you buy
products that display either the RSPO
or green palm labels because those
labels indicate that the palm all that's
gone into that product was produced in a
sustainable way also where possible just
try to not buy products that contain
palm oil if there is an alternative
available and there are some fantastic
links online such as some in the
description that give you mister
products that are suitable alternative
it's basically impossible to not buy
products that contain palm oil but by
buying palm oil products that contain
sustainably sourced palm oil sends a
message to those companies that don't
engage in sustainable practices we the
people want to live in an
environmentally conscious well so let us
number six recycle this one isn't going
to save you any money but it's certainly
going to do the environment a lot of
good recycling is one of the easiest
ways that you can reduce your personal
environmental impact and here in the UK
about sixty percent of the stuff that
we've put in the bin we can actually
recycle that's not even including food
waste that you could also compost a
recent study done in scotland suggests
that recycling aluminium such as sanding
coke cans and save up to seven tons of
co2 being emitted per ton of aluminum
process relative to it just being chats
and landfill and making more and then
lessor savings for other materials like
paper and plastic and the carbon side of
recycling is only one aspect of it by
not recycling paper you are directly
contributing to global deforestation and
degradation of vulnerable habitats and
i'm recycle plastic isn't going anywhere
for the next 500 years which sucks
especially when all that plastic
inevitably ends up in the ocean and so
sucks even more if you're a fish or a
turtle at the end of the day you could
be doing the environment several favors
by just putting your rubbish in a
slightly different colored bin and maybe
taking two seconds to sort it in to
blast metal paper and plastic and as a
student I know how lazy we are but come
on guys pull some weight to the team
here at number seven get engaged with
your campus
scheme because the universities are full
of searingly intelligent people such as
here itself almost every uni will either
have an official or a student-led
organization that's dedicated to not
screwing over the apartment quite so
hard he wrecks stuff when I'm doing my
PhD that is the green unit who helped me
put together this video thank you guys
thanks in part to work from the green
unit our uni has extensive recycling
Overton campus lots of water fountains
that allow the reuse of plastic bottles
multiple schemes that encourage students
to get involved in sustainability and
conservation work and classes like slow
cooking though it gets students to move
away from processed foods and ready
meals that are really resource intensive
Exeter is exceptional in this regard but
your uni will have similar schemes in
place and if you think they're not doing
enough and you have an idea that you'd
like super into place then go and take
it to them because you needs are defined
by what their students do and while
chugging DK's and sleeping in the
library is undoubtedly important a
culture of respect for the environment
and awareness of sustainability is
something that I think we can add to our
national student identity and make a
real difference so there you go all very
achievable ways that you as a student
can reduce your impact on the
environment and if you have any specific
further tips that you'd like to share
and please put them in the comments
below and we can all get a bit more eco
friendly together and make sure you
check the description below this video
for all the links that I've been
referring to thanks for watching now go
save the world
you
you